I guess like being like out here like in
Skid Row like you hear you hear one
story and you know everyone's been
molested everyone's been abused
everyone's been you know domestic
violence I mean there's these things
that become like a way of life and so
normal but they really do you know they
really mess you up you know they really
like yeah I mean I know that from all
these things that I've gone through in
my life I know that I'm a broken person
you know and because I don't choose to
get help you know I I stay running from
it you know all right Samantha where you
grew up I grew up in the Riverside moved
to the Coachella Valley like the lower
desert when I was 14 came out here to LA
four years ago and you grew up with
parents one day um I was back and forth
between my mom my dad like my whole life
but my parents divorced when I was five
so yeah like I was between my mom my dad
up until I was 18 like back and forth
back and forth and then my childhood was
pretty like consistent with like that of
an addict
I was must buy my babies
seven I'm the only female babysitter I'm
female
yeah female I didn't even tell my mom
until like two years ago I had the
morning what yeah it was like a
consistent
that happened for a while I kind of I
think back and I noticed like a lot of
things in my childhood were you know
like weren't supposed to happen you know
but I got involved with somebody when I
was 14 I got pregnant 15 with that
person and by the time I was 18 and he
was like 19 we needed up having to serve
six years for great bodily injury that
he he nearly killed me so like a piece
of relationship yeah that was just the
first one yeah I had a I had a couple
and then and then like verbal verbally
abusive more like the mental and
emotional abuse was probably more
damaging than anything like I mean I
look back now and it really took its
toll on me you know
yeah do you think any event might have
come from your dad
oh absolutely would you like that um my
dad is very like withdrawn he kind of um
he told me a couple years ago that he's
pretty much accepted the fact that I'm
like I'm out here and I could possibly
die but I mean at this point I'm doing
like what could kill a person like
twenty times that a fentanyl today like
and that's just to say well you know so
he's right but it's how hard you know my
dad it's hard to hear that I mean my mom
just passed away two and a half months
ago
just running and gunning out here
first started the drug was 14 I tried
heroin heroin yeah turns out first
ecstasy and like cocaine and I had like
my phases with all the drugs like I did
it with with my friends so I thought was
like it was it was cool and I just kind
of went like all my friends went this
way and I like you're right like or left
yeah I went well all my friends right
now we're actually getting married and
like buying houses and stuff and I'm
like chemistry yeah and what do you do
for money okay well just hang you like
to say I haven't like
done a date before I'm relying but
fortunately you like right now I am in a
situation where I mean I guess not all
of us women out here like weed weed like
we use our bodies to get you know I mean
like in one way or another we use our
bodies to get what we need and I mean
fortunately I don't have to sleep around
but you know it's like a game we playing
you know yeah I see the guys recycling
pretty much yeah and crazy stories oh
yeah well I mean like a pain well I'll
tell you like what like a normal day
like in Skid Row like one day I was like
while I was walking up seventh and I saw
like a lady she they used the fire
hydrant to get the water you know like
to bathe and whatever else but she was
like bathing in the fire hydrant and
like I mean it's just it's so it's like
so crazy down here and like I think like
all the crazy [ __ ] that's going on
around me like that's what takes you out
of you know your reality like that's how
I mean that's how I'm able to stay out
here like you know every day I'm not I'm
not think about you know I mean like
what I'm what I'm running from it's
there's so much [ __ ] going on and it's
not yours
ridiculous
you think is a product of the chocolate
I have to say um I have to say a lot
like I was really spoiled momma's little
spoiled I grew up like really entitled
and I mean I didn't have to want
branding but there was like my my
parents would like kind of just shut the
door and like leave me to my own devices
you know so I didn't get like a lot of
like the nurturing and you know I just
like I remember my I remember a lot of
my childhood my parents were suicidal
like depressed like so I think that like
that when I grew up like like even adult
that's how I learned it so I learned to
do that you know I mean like I tried to
kill myself when I was 15 you know and I
mean I really tried to kill myself like
I wasn't I checked like a bunch of
different pills like how they took one
more probably different trying to filled
up her methadone
he said I would like for sure I didn't I
I was on fifty to fifty I've had like
three of those you know just at one
point I had three years clean you know I
was like doing a program and Narcotics
Anonymous
I am I ended up getting pregnant with
the person that I was with the time and
I it resulted in like an ectopic so I
needed surgery
kids hi one daughter she's um she's 10
my brother's raising her yeah my brother
and his wife
I wish do you spend it's 150 a day yeah
can you use it multiple times throughout
the day
pretty much on I mean all day like it's
like I mean you're honest all day if I
could you know but yeah as much as I can
I don't know like it's a different kind
of
the different kind of demon it's not
like heroin it's like worse it's like
yeah there's no there's a bigger desire
stronger desire to get it and to get
light to fix and and all that and it's
fun it's harder to do like it's just
weird it's hard to find you know it's
it's weird there's like a little
subculture a little bit home part of
downtown
skipper oh [ __ ] our life
27:24
if I chose if I chose to yeah like they
they will still talk to me you know
basically I'll use just put put down the
needle and like you know agree to
treatment when I couldn't you know step
in and everybody's life again so I guess
I'm choosing this
you know I see it they're talking to
hundreds and hundreds of people is
whatever happened you as a child kind of
set that mindset where you believe you
deserve thank the crap you're going
through until if you fix that you can
get clean and you can move to Beverly
Hills and you can do anything you want
but you'll end up back here until you
fix that mindset that makes you believe
you deserve this yeah cuz I talked to
think that this is where they belong
they love it here this is where I belong
well I was sleeping the like the little
area in front of the tent and uh and I'm
like this is like I feel like it's
normal it's totally normal for me like
I'm just sweeping the gutter like and
people are fine driving by like taking
pictures like it's I don't I don't know
anything but this right now like it's
weird no book at you you're beautiful
young girl you can easily clean up and
in about an afternoon head of hair cut
your nails Reverend
Oh see that's where it's like weird
because I don't feel like I fit in there
at all yeah so I feel like I wait for
couple years and then there and that's
really the problem right it's not the
drugs it's not the homelessness it's not
them it's me like it's your belief that
you deserve this this is like this is
okay yeah you think this is okay I can't
believe anybody could tolerate those who
these people actually you're attracted
to
yeah like that's crazy okay so you can
get off the drugs all you like but
you'll end up back here no kidding yeah
cuz it's it's it's just all too easy
this is it like no I'm better that was
good
got me thinking